tentacles do you know how expensive that
shot was when the robots are literally
just like freaking sprinting down the
highway yeah well that's me and the
mocap running
how does one animate an owl
hey
welcome to another episode
starters to react today is
that none other than Matthew demero here
on the couch with us animation
supervisor at Agora Studios he's been on
the streets for 20 years animated
so as you said I've been prostituting
myself for 20 years
animating for various Studios so I've
spanned from Feature work to visual
effects animation through a ton of
different titles the Marvel stuff the
Transformers stuff Lego Movie just a
span of of a ton of cool projects and
fun projects well let's jump in
action of the Guardians the owls our
longest most requested reaction Legend
of the Guardians owls of gahul we
finally going to talk about that but
with a person that actually worked on it
I did
so this is a Zack Snyder production how
15 years ago it's a while so what was
your responsibility on this show I was a
lead and this is the biggest team I've
ever had to lead which grew to 1516
artists by the end wow this was a
Monumental project but it was super fun
and we had a very talented team it was a
really really good project to work on
the big scene that people wanted to talk
about was the rain scene yeah
you worked in the chat yeah yeah perfect
inside
here we go
somebody saw the Matrix not the first
one but the third one
those feathers look great in the water
dude it's one thing to animate a bird
flying it's another to animate a bird
through a storm I think that comes down
to staging and having a loud pass and a
loud pass is what happens before
animation so there's a whole department
that's placing cameras and and making
them Dynamic and moving to characters in
space and and for this show we even had
like speedometers to go okay they fly at
about this speed and that way they could
have the cameras moving at a right speed
so for in this case I make sure the
cameras are moving in the right
direction so the rain goes the right
direction and then animating like
getting those little inching forward and
getting the feeling that they're pulling
back and actually animating that how the
flaps are more labored and all that
stuff and then and then all the feathers
and all that that just sells everything
and they make us look so and it's so
good all these departments so there's
obvious obviously a lot of like
simulation stuff happening here between
all of the feathers and the water and
the raindrops and all that stuff but as
an animator you're responsible for the
bass line correct how does one animate
an owl I mean there's obviously there's
a lot of Liberties taken you'd can find
like sometimes like you know footage of
a an eagle falling or a bird somebody
captured that and you can kind of take
inspiration from that but then you're
like well is it is it cinematic enough a
lot of these birds that we see in movies
often are animated slower because and
especially for a movie like this where
they're talking and they're they're
interacting they've almost become people
and so they can't act like if an owl is
this big they move very very quickly
they they're gone in two frames so you
can't have that for a movie where it's
supposed to be a dramatic exit yeah and
it's the big guy right it's like it's
it's the big furry one who's the biggest
one of them and the real live action
footage is like let's say three frames
together like no I'm gonna take like
half a second or something like that I I
really get the push on the thing to make
him feel heavy because if not I don't
think the audience could connect to them
so you almost are animating these owls
as if they're six foot tall human beings
pretty much interesting yeah so when
you're animating you're not just getting
a million feathers all physically
simulated in real time when you move
your wing around right so I'm assuming
those are added after the fact but if
you're to pluck all the feathers off a
novel you just end up with this weird
potato with like two sticks coming out
is that what you're animating is a
potato with two sticks coming up
I mean that would have been pretty
challenging so for the wings you did the
primaries which are the most important
feathers that are there and we had
control over them so if ever you wanted
a gap or you wanted something or we
could put some noise on them and then on
top of that all the other stuff would
get sent so some feathers are built into
the model that you're animating and
other feathers are added later correct
in terms of the potato
um you would get a volume of the body
okay which essentially is just geometry
that represents the overall size okay so
now not just the skin like as if you're
to shrink wrap the owl correct
interesting okay correct so you added me
to that so if ever there's a design
change that has to get updated because
then we can get the proportions so that
when you're animating and you're putting
them you know trying to get certain
Silhouettes or whatever you've got the
right sizes that you're working with the
type of olive that Soren is imagine if
you pluck the feathers off the head of
the owl kind of looks like any other
Bird yeah but like that specific shape
of like the the almost like plates the
you know tea saucers around the eyes
coming to like the Peak at the nose like
that's all part of you need that for
like the expressions of course yeah yeah
and so you just have like a kind of
simplified geometric version of that
when you're animated well for the faces
they're more detailed because we need to
have the remote the lower Lids all that
is there but the little tiny feathers
know like maybe we had a texture to make
it look nicer so when we're presenting
to to Zach and stuff like that he knows
what he's looking at and it feels more
appealing but no the feathers are not
there there's some pretty impressive
stuff going on I mean obviously there's
crazy simulations and really beautiful
rendering and all this kind of stuff but
the thing that really hits me is just
like this feeling of that they are
flying and moving forwards when in
reality all we're seeing is just a model
going like this and like feathers waving
in the wind like it just feels so alive
I mean the idea of all these individual
feathers being wet and like moving on
the owl as well and I guess you guys
have to make it look like it's an actual
owl while still doing a little bit of a
cartoon but a lot of it is it is I think
what makes this so successful is a
combination of all these departments
working well together and I think that
plays a big part
you've got to be kidding me I know I
know we have looked at Transformers so
many times at this point well we're
looking at it again and we're gonna look
at it more in the future because that's
just how it is say what you will about
the stories of those movies those are
technologically artistic masterpieces I
worked on three four and five okay
Transformers was my favorite TV show as
a kid I used to watch it in French and
English because I'm French Canadian so I
got to watch double the Transformers on
Saturday mornings like I was so excited
I was so excited to work on on these
movies I got in got a basic simple shot
to animate with a hand clawing at a
parking structure and then they had
nothing simpler to give me so they
actually gave me a really cool shot he's
got the shield and he smashes a
helicopter and then then the slice is
another thing and just bang bang just
demolishing stuff in a hanger
the highway chase scene in Transformers
3 is honestly incredible it was my
favorite moment of the entire movie when
the robots are literally just like
freaking sprinting down the highway just
like that feeling of like here's a
massive thing just sprinting and the
legs are moving so fast well that's me
and the mocap running
[Laughter]
had you done any mocap before then I
assisted on on sets uh for mocap shoots
on other stuff this is the first time
getting suited up with everything and
doing the whole deal so one thing
Michael would always ask I want a
different transformation I want them to
be different so for that at that point
This was later in the show they say hey
Matt do you want to come up with a new
transformation and so I just kind of
chopped up the Geo of the trucks and
just kind of like oh what if they kind
of break in half and then you can roll
and do that and they're like yep
and that's a fun little fact in the
middle of the camera pivots and when we
looked at the plate Michael was like why
did we turn the camera I think it was
always supposed to go straight so it was
a bit of a mistake that they did on set
but instead we chose to highlight he was
like well let's do something with it so
we highlighted the fact that the panther
gets shot and he hits the median and
then the camera kind of pulls on him and
then I think we warped a little bit like
time warped it so Michael didn't
actually want the camera to Nestle turn
around when he looked at the actual
stickers like no that wasn't actually
the way the shot was supposed to work
and you're like but what if we just made
something really cool happen and then
he's like I like that idea yeah and this
is kind of the result of that so that's
a great way to make lemons out of
lemonade right there yep dang okay the
shot after you might recognize it from
another film oh I know about that oh you
know about that
why do you cut to a shot from the island
here
because you know how expensive that shot
was
oh it's the the plate when you see the
the plate it's a big metal thing that
sticks out of the road and they just
drive that car just straight out yeah
and just slap them into it and I think
it was just like this is a perfect shot
for this moment I'm reusing my plate
yeah absolutely the median's completely
different
no one cares no one's looking at that
you know the shot of all the car is
flipping and then you go to the point of
view shot you can just see it this like
straight up like ramrod from the cannon
just flying past camera that big
cylinder that's bouncing along the road
though it's like a gas tank that's one
of the big Ram rods they have in the
Cannons underneath the car to launch it
when it flips it's that shot out of the
car right there oh that's how they
flipped it yeah yeah and it just looks
like debris yeah no one would have any
ideas they're just like no I'll just
leave it in there's like tree you can
see it's smoking on the end it just adds
to it though like that's the chaos with
the technology we have someone could
have painted that out yeah and I spent
days doing that but instead it's like
okay yeah I want that it looks better it
does yeah yeah and that's the thing when
you're filming real destruction like
preserve and cherish the beauty of chaos
because you even on a computer you just
can't quite get it it doesn't have the
same fine detail of real life so you
continued on from Transformers 3 and did
you move immediately into Transformers
4. yeah I did get to jump back on to the
Transformers world I continue to do
mocap and there's very much a shot of me
walking so the shot you're describing is
the one where like the dudes walking out
of the smoke and he's got the big [ __ ]
behind him that's like I feel like
that's one of the more iconic shots from
this movie it was in the trailer it's so
foreboding it's like oh this is the
villain yeah and for a lot of animators
we we do pay attention to a lot of
details on how people walk and all that
stuff and any of my friends that worked
in animation that known me for a while
were like that is you that is exactly
you walking but I'm sure the animated
that did it'll probably slowed it down a
little bit I'm pretty short so I move
pretty quick can I see you do the walk
from the door to us this is what 10
years ago I'm gonna imagine this giant
spaceship behind you are you ready yep
all right
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 100 yep
dude it's on the shoulders it's in the
shoulder road
but it's just funny because anyone that
worked with me that knew me were like oh
man that's you
oh Hey Jeffrey nice to see you again I
see you're still not subscribed and that
kind of breaks my heart
it's okay though I'm used to that
but if you subscribe it might be better
just saying
Pentacles
[Music]
so we were told by another animator that
tentacles are hard to deal with they are
I've always had fun doing that sort of
stuff I like the messiness of it it is
it's not easy that's for sure and we
were fortunate enough to have really
good rigs because what happens is
sometimes tentacles grab sometimes they
slip sometimes they stick to things and
so in order to have a rig that can
handle all those moments you need to be
able to switch to different modes if you
will so that tentacle also has
controlled a certain way then it's
controlled a different way do you have
like a rule set that you internally try
to follow when you animate tentacles in
this case like you just saw two
tentacles doing this right so it's it's
about making that aesthetically pleasing
in the shapes and that you can almost go
back to the base of Animation the most
important thing I need to tell the story
here is this tentacle wraps around this
guy and then throws them up in the air
so you start with that and then you can
how do I set dress this how do I make
the composition interesting and then and
then you try to work diligently on the
contacts with the grounds and all that
and all the different little emotions we
did have some procedural stuff for the
back tentacles where you could just turn
on a thing and the tentacles okay I was
actually wondering like why why go the
animation route when you can probably
just write some code and have the
tentacles do the technical things well
because you've got you've got screen
Direction and you've got shot
composition and you've got art Direction
and and I'm sure with newer AI maybe
maybe I'll be replaced
and then I will do the tentacles but
essentially that's what that's why you
can't do those moments like that but
that was a fun sequence to work on what
other tentacles have you animated like
have there been other tentacles there's
been many tentacles I got to do some on
Skull Island
[Music]
so I got to do a few shots like that I
really really wanted the one where he's
really eating it oh and I only got the
last slurp somebody else got the other
shot because the other artist is also
really really good at doing tentacles
but I really wanted that but no one
wanted those
like I'll do it so did you pull up old
boy to reference that Yes actually yes
it was the reference that was the
reference that we're asked to do but I
think some of the logistics of the size
of the tentacles didn't quite work Randy
know about the reference that we're
talking about from old boy I've never
seen old boy but I know the reference
you're talking about yeah so yeah the
actor ate a live octopus on set very
intense we probably this will be on the
website I guess discretion advise he
eats a live octopus
but yeah tentacles they're your worst
nightmare but if you like them it can be
a lot of fun I want to see more
tentacles in movies if you got any
suggestions for the most tentacle
tentacles
leave a comment down below you can get
lots of inappropriate suggestions like
moves like
recent TV shows that's like live action
anime
I mean we looked at so much today and it
was all Epic we finally looked at
guardians of gahoul that wasn't Google
Legend of the Guardians owls of gold
yeah Matt it was an honor having you on
the couch with us today it was really
cool getting that inside perspective of
what it's like to actually do animation
in movies today and I don't think we
would have gotten that otherwise so
thank you it's my pleasure please check
out the Agora Community uh that is a
wonderful place to learn and to uh
potentially improve your skills awesome
stuff we'll have a link in the
description below if that interests you
and you want to actually delve into this
this work is it just like a movie you
want people to watch I think people
should watch the Rover the Rover by
David micho the Rover fantastic movie
that no one has watched that's right if
you haven't heard of it go check it out
none of us on the couch have anything to
do with this movie
yeah I just want you to see it